Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill bard is time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast and Ah,
just checking in on you.
I'm just checking and just seeing how your week's going,
you know,
I would think if I was in New York Yankee Fan,
despite the fact we're only a couple of games up for the one game playoff,
I would say that I'm having a pretty good fucking Thursday,
you know?
Do you see the last couple of games?
Did you see last night's game in particular?
I'm going to tell you guys right now,
I am going to gradually wean you off of watching ESPN,
Fox sports west,
listening to the fan.
Okay?
Nobody gets it right?
More Times in my own mind,
in my own world,
without doing any research on how any of those other people,
how many times they get it right?
Nobody gets it right more than the man you're listening to right fucking now.
What the fuck did I say?
Well,
Bill,
you,
you've said a lot of things.
All right,
fair enough.
I have said a lot of things and I mentioned this fucking wire sucks.
Jesus Christ.
God forbid I turned my fucking,
this is unbelievable.
It's a brand new fucking wire.
Does anything work?
Is this how like China is going to slowly like they know they can't fucking bomb
us,
right?
So what do they do?
They just make everything just a little bit,
not fucking right and it just,
it's going to gradually drive him fucking crazy.
Now what do I do?
I've got to move this thing over here.
Bring this up because God forbid this,
any weight on this wire,
the second thing is weight.
All of a sudden it doesn't work.
Now it totally does it.
Come on.
I need to hear myself.
I need to hear myself talking about how great I am.
All right,
there you go.
Um,
I told you motherfuckers,
I love how I'm mad at you guys.
Like you ever said no you didn't bill,
you never told us that.
Right?
Fuck is my water.
Oh Jesus.
This can be one of these dow.
There it is.
Um,
I told you way back in fucking August when the red sox swept the Yankees and
ESPN fucking over
what's over ESPN.
Oh,
I guess maybe a divisional race.
Who gives a fuck?
You know what I mean?
There's still the wildcard
still the fucking wow.
That's like there's an ax murderer or outside your fucking house and you just
lock the front door and you leave the back door wide open.
You're like,
well I guess that takes care of that.
Not to mention if you have a wood door,
you know,
but so motivated axe murderer,
he could just chop down the door.
Okay.
Jay actually would work in your,
it gives you time to try
to find something to defend.
Defend yourself is acts,
you know,
technically speaking will be a little more dull cause it goes through the front
door.
This is all beside the point.
I told you motherfuckers back then I was,
I can tell David Price goes into the fucking metaphor.
New Custodian wintered Goddamn game.
I don't give a fuck that were out there sweeping the Baltimore Orioles.
All right.
Regular season stats.
You know what that's like.
That's like the guy who was the fucking big man on campus in high school.
Right?
He's a fucking lie.
He's a captain at is.
He's got the dimple in his fucking chair and he's banging a fucking cheerleader.
Right?
And everybody's like,
oh my God,
Hey,
it's Katie's going to be the president right
now.
What happens?
You go back to the reunion and he looks like,
may no,
you got me.
I'm just saying
like it doesn't make a difference if you win 89 games or fucking 129 games.
What murders is how you're doing against the fucking teams that you're going to
see in October.
You know?
But that's not the business that does those so and so's over and ESPN and Fox
News and whoever else.
I'm,
I'm lumping into the same fucking category.
That's not the game they're in.
They're in the game of what the fuck you see is what the fuck it is.
And we will hype the shit out of it and not even remotely look at it
analytically.
Okay.
So then if what happens happens,
you can be,
like I said,
it was going to happen,
but what you said was going to happen doesn't happen.
Then you get to do the,
what happened?
What happened was you got a namerd by a bunch of fucking victories against the
Orioles in the fucking tigers in bunches.
These are Jake,
Jake.
I mean huge guys.
Gate gate hit like over 9,000 home run junior regular season.
And you were absolutely anemic in the playoffs.
Well,
yeah.
Well how did they do against the fucking Astros?
Sorry.
Anyways,
you know what?
You know what that's like the,
it's like watching Paul.
I love Paul to death.
I got to get him on the,
I have to get him on this fucking podcast cause I'm always making fun of them
and I want you guys to know that it comes from a place of love.
All right?
Most of the times it comes from a place of love for right now.
It comes from a place of concern.
Yeah.
Okay.
One of the dumbest fucking things that you can do.
Yeah.
Besides buying a fucking God damn fucking speaker wire for I'm,
I'm blaming it on China.
Okay.
It's a,
it's always a great guest.
Everything's fucking made over there.
All right.
It's like when,
when you get you eating a doughnut,
you're like,
what?
What's the main ingredient gradient in here?
The one guests you have is corn.
Okay.
Corners in everything.
If you don't believe me,
watch the one documentary I ever watched about and
have now are using that as my Bible.
I saw it years ago,
so I'm probably misquoting it.
All right?
Having said that,
no one I just said was a fact.
One of the dumbest things you could do is the first game of the week bet a bunch
of fucking games.
All right?
And I'm not talking about fantasies shit.
And I'm not talking about all the people,
the sports gambling podcasts that I read a advertising than I told you to to go
out and do that exact fucking thing.
So this is be hypocritical now for me to tell you this,
but I,
you know,
you don't know who the fuck anybody is until about two,
three fucking weeks in.
All right?
I've tried to tell Paul Versey this poverty is the king of betting football,
college or pro.
In fact,
when I first became friends with him back when college football wasn't brilliant
enough to realize that they needed to have some good match ups in the first few
weeks to get people into it,
to pull them away from the NFL and this,
this is what's happening.
You know,
even though I haven't looked at the ratings,
okay,
I'm saying it's happening,
therefore it is happening.
Okay?
Now these goddamn feminists and me tours can just say things happen without any
evidence.
And God damn it,
I can say this is happening with no evidence,
no research,
no nothing to write fucking college football is,
is,
is getting better ratings right now than the national football league.
Dare I say a presidential address.
Okay.
Now,
if Netflix doesn't have to give out ratings,
then why should I have to look at him?
That's what I say.
Um,
yeah.
Anyways,
Po,
uh,
this is like 10 fucking years ago,
12 years ago,
and at first knew Paul,
this is back when they had all the cupcake games,
you know,
to establish the rankings for whatever reason they would have like Ohio State
Doh play,
uh,
Eleanor Rigby.
He's fucking nursing home,
right?
Nursing School of nursing or some shit,
And then there would be a favored by like fucking 80 points and fucking Versie
would go out.
And just the first week of football,
you know,
being a college coach is so much harder than being a pro professionals,
uh,
coach.
Simply because every three,
you know,
three,
four years,
you've got a brand new fucking team.
You're just constantly,
every year is a fucking rebuilding year.
And now all these God damn millennials,
which they're not millennials once again,
1980 to 1995,
there are 23 to 38 years old.
I actually just told a 38 year old woman yesterday that she was a millennial and
she couldn't fucking believe.
I said,
yes,
you are.
According to the one website that I went to and didn't even look at a second one
to even back it up.
You are a millennial.
And she said,
I don't identify as millennial.
And I was like,
are you angling for your own bathroom?
Um,
I don't know.
I'm doing this right now cause I don't even know what the fuck's going on in the
world right now.
I just know it's a fucking,
everybody is in a Goddamn hissy fit about everything.
So I just know,
and I know that you don't need evidence,
you don't need fucking anything.
People just say things and then it's not only the person that did the thing,
it's the person that stood next to the guy that did the fucking thing.
So in the future,
God forbid God for fucking bed,
you're standing on a subway platform and somebody jumps in front of a train to
commit suicide.
Um,
they're going to blame you for assisted suicide because you stood there and did
nothing.
I'm sorry.
That's probably a slight exaggeration.
It's probably bear,
you know,
I probably should have read up on the story a little more.
I probably don't know what I'm talking about.
Okay.
I probably won't even upload this,
but I might.
But if you're listening to it,
you know,
are dead.
So Versie would go out any fucking would just,
just the first week of college football.
You have no idea who the fuck anybody anybody is.
And he would just,
he would just do it.
It's a law.
I mean,
it's literally a joke.
Nebraska be given 58 and he'd fucking bed on the favor.
Right?
He's doing it again this year.
All right.
Last week he fucking bets.
Uh,
you know,
he's got that fucking homecoming theory,
a good road team coming off a loss playing the next week,
add home.
He doesn't give a fuck how many fucking points that given.
He can't lay off it.
So we keeps calling the lions,
the hapless lions,
that hapless lines.
It's just like,
dude,
they,
their first game of the year,
they had a shit one.
Okay,
everybody's going to have a shit game.
The fucking patriots just had a shit game against the Jag was,
but it was week two.
So nobody's saying that that's who they are.
But last year they had a shit game against Kansas City and all of a sudden the
whole for all the wheels were off.
The Tom Brady era was over.
And what ended up happening,
all Tommy Brady brought us right back to the fucking super bowl.
He threw for 500 yards over 500 yards in the game and he lost it was our defense
suck that game,
you know?
Um,
cause they will,
they only held,
nick falls to over 300 yards,
which I guess was a great day.
If the other guy threw for 500 bucks a day,
if we don't come out with victory,
didn't want it to me.
MMM.
So last week for as he's telling me that the lions,
the hapless lines,
you'd take Jimmy g coming home,
San Francisco,
it's a lock and he's texting me,
the whole game is San Francisco is winning.
Say,
what did I say?
I set it all week.
Exclamation points.
He's an absolute euphoria that he said
something that now look like it was going to happen.
And he's looking at Matthew Stafford like this fucking guy likes to lose every
week.
Like this guy doesn't have any pride,
man.
It can't get out there fucking rock.
And next thing you know,
the fucking lines come back in the end and they end up covering the spread.
Now we've all fucking been there.
All right?
So you learn from your past.
Well,
if you don't learn from your past,
you wouldn't keep gambling,
but now you come back for more.
What does versus do again this week?
He's teasing the Patriots.
The play.
I think that,
I don't know.
Somebody is playing.
He keeps calling him the hapless lions because they had one bad fucking week.
So now the lines of playing the Patriots are former fucking coach is coaching
the team.
He's been what he went and what Ma fucking Patricia.
They're like,
that guy doesn't know some of the shit that we do.
Okay.
Now I'm not saying the Patriots won't go in and kick the fucking shit up and I
send a page is okay?
Yeah.
All right.
See,
I don't know what the fuck I'm saying.
I'm just saying
you just lost betting against this fucking tape and you're still calling them
the hapless fucking lions.
They were on the road,
they almost beat the fucking 40 niners
they had one bad fucking game.
All right.
And this brings me back to the fucking red sox.
Alright.
They sweep
the Yankees or the beginning of August and everybody fucking,
and all these guys in these fucking sports shows,
they put their tasseled fucking loafers up on the desk,
you know,
full their fingers on top of their head and that's fucking over it.
So it's,
it ain't over.
It's not over.
It's not fucking over.
So my prediction,
the Red Sox,
uh,
I just don't think we,
we don't have the fucking one two punch.
We don't have a one and two as far as I'm concerned in our starting rotation
that you need.
You know,
we just don't have it.
So I think we're going to win a bunch of fucking games and then we are going to
lose in the playoffs.
I don't want that to happen.
I didn't want to say that to you.
I don't want to ruin your fucking day.
But you know,
until a price starts fucking winning and Yankee Stadium,
I just don't fucking see it.
Unless we're going to play for straight fucking gay or I'll,
I'll,
you know,
only have him start at home.
Oh my God,
I love the guy.
He's a fucking amazing pitcher and everything and I really needed him to win
last night.
I needed it.
Okay.
I needed it because,
you know,
I,
I lived through sports.
That's,
that's how,
that's what I do.
Okay.
There.
Does that make you feel better?
It's not enough then.
I'm a 50 year old man alone in a room right now talking into a microphone,
hoping somebody is listening,
nodding in agreement.
Almost didn't get through that word.
Listening,
listening.
Um,
and we'll have things you'll want to talk about.
I will.
Two,
this is like my own Mr. Rogers show.
You know,
it's a beautiful day in the neighborhood,
a beautiful day in the neighbor.
Here comes the current through the fucking door.
He has always wanted to be right about something in sports,
even though it has no effect on his life.
So let's all fucking listen to this shit.
Send them some emails and say,
dude,
that was it.
You figured it out.
You're a genius.
Go Fuck Yourself.
You're red con sorry.
Um,
go fuck yourself.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I always have to finish the song.
Please go fuck yourself.
You freckled current.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
I have not been watching the news and been working on writing a script right
now,
so I haven't been watching anything and it's fucking hilarious to not watch the
news to not what's no,
what's going on.
Okay.
Because all your friends,
it just constantly,
or just sending you texts.
All caps.
Are you watching this or they call you up?
Dude,
did you see this?
Did you see that Mark Cuban thing?
Okay?
Did you see what Trump said?
Yeah.
Did you hear about the fuck an Albatross?
Okay.
The Dj Dj's.
Did you see what happened in Bolivia?
It's fucking hell.
It's never anything good.
Never.
Never anything fucking good.
Um,
anyways,
so I,
I don't,
I don't know what's going on.
I did watch the Mark Cuban thing for like a minute,
man.
That was fucking a,
that was brutal.
That now that,
that right there,
that that's,
that's one of them.
Brutal ones
late.
No,
maybe there's eight.
maybe that,
that's just straight up.
That's just fucking
Jesus Christ.
I don't know.
You know,
I got to tell you here it's this podcast,
like that's not the way we run our business here.
Now.
The genius of my podcast is there's,
there's nobody else here.
Therefore I can't get in trouble.
Okay.
I don't send emails to myself.
At no point will I ever be on the ESPN of podcasting,
sitting there,
shifting,
uncomfortably,
trying to answer questions that I have the answers to.
I just don't want to tell them to you because I know it's,
it's,
I did the wrong thing.
Um,
or maybe,
maybe in the future they'll,
there'll be something like that.
You know,
I want to see what
is a woman going to be fucking squirming.
What about that woman who fucking date rape?
The 17 year old guy who fucking was talking all that shit about Harvey Weinstein
and then she fucking paid the kid off and then blamed it on a dead guy.
Where,
why isn't she shifting around?
Ask and answer and fucking uncomfortable fucking questions.
You know,
sometimes it's deer season,
sometimes it's elk season.
I guess it's still deer season.
I can't,
what?
When,
when is it going to flip up?
When is it going to flip around?
MMM.
That's why I don't look at this shit.
I saw this woman she wrote on like Twitter.
She's just like,
oh,
this one guy,
he was able to come out back after fucking six months and it wasn't six months.
It was close to a year.
So they already fucking shaved off some months and uh,
Monica Lewinsky wasn't able to come back for 20 years.
It's like,
what are you talking about?
And she goes,
and she did nothing wrong.
Well,
I think Hillary would probably debate that.
MMM.
It's like she hosted SNL.
She wrote a fucking book.
She had a line of purses.
She had a show.
They tried to get on the air.
If she,
not only she fucking became a cottage industry off of that thing.
It's like,
what are you talking about?
MMM.
Anyways,
I don't know.
I,
that's,
it's just like at this,
this fucking thing that women are doing that with all,
they just keep peeking over the fence and all this scene is green grass.
You know,
I,
I don't,
I just don't fucking,
it's like what are you looking?
That's all you see.
You only see green grass.
Yeah.
Engages fucking show up and people just given stop.
If a guy did something wrong happens.
If a woman just shut the fuck up,
they sound like fucking five.
I'm not saying there aren't double standards,
everything,
but like what did you pick one that's actually a double standard so you don't
have to fudge shit that stingy a whole thing is just going to fucking collapsed.
Or maybe you do research.
This woman actually said she's on her fucking stump.
She's saying after the Monica Lewinsky thing that Bill Clinton was those then
reelected.
It's like he wasn't,
it happened in his second term.
Do a little research.
I mean what,
what,
what do you mean
and we'll have things we'll want to yell about.
Okay.
I will
to,
um,
when a woman brushes your teeth,
she can feel the whole toothpastes community judging her.
When a guy brushes his teeth,
they're like,
oh,
we should run the company.
Okay,
next time you're in traffic,
stop and go traffic ladies.
Just,
just look at the,
look on the guy's faces.
Look at the cars they're driving
to.
Any of them look like they're even in remote control remotely in fucking control
of their lives.
Okay,
ladies,
be honest with yourselves,
okay.
In the average relationship,
boyfriend,
girlfriend,
okay.
Married.
Whatever life partners the end of the day,
okay.
If she wants to get brunch and the guy doesn't know what the,
what do you think you're going to do?
Yeah.
What is the guy's options?
Does he have any at the end of the day,
who's really calling the shots?
If only one person has life insurance,
okay.
If there's only one fucking person that's going to benefit from the other
person's death on average,
who is that person?
Huh?
Let me come on people.
Happy wife.
Happy life.
Where's the cute little rhyme for the guy?
There isn't one.
It's cause we don't matter.
Look how they hype Valentine's Day.
Okay?
It's all about the woman.
Why?
Because they know that every guy is living the fucking male female dynamic,
which is keep it happy.
Maybe it will fuck me keeping happy.
Maybe I can watch the game,
keep it happy.
Maybe I can enjoy 20 minutes of my weekend.
That is what that is the world most men are living in.
But if you go on the Internet and you go on social media,
most men are blocking a doorway while jizzing on a plant then running a company
telling you when you're in traffic,
just look,
look,
it's,
I'm telling you,
you just look at the side of somebody's head and you know who the fuck they are.
You can see how much hope they have left.
All right.
I challenge you.
Why does that thing doing that shit?
No.
Um,
a challenge.
I challenge you to find a lot of hopeful fucking guys out there.
Did you see that?
Somebody else told me that night.
I actually looked it up.
That fucking that without that woman out there,
uh,
in,
in Hawaii telling men,
did you shut up and do the right thing for once?
It's a fucking,
she's hold political office and it's just talking like that.
Just shut up and do the right thing.
All the guys asking for is,
is to,
how to say his side of the story.
She's basically saying,
shut up.
Don't listen to the guys' side of the story.
As this woman says all these things,
it's going to destroy this guy's career.
I'm not saying what the woman is saying is true or isn't true,
but the guy,
he doesn't even have the right to defend himself.
Dang.
For once.
Okay.
All right.
How about we do that when you push away from the buffet table,
Oh,
there's a nice low blow for you and I am proud of doing it.
I'll take the 10 minute misconduct.
That's what it's becoming.
It's becoming literally shut the fuck up.
All guys shut up and listen to one side of the fucking story and then that's the
story.
You know the story is my story.
Your story doesn't count because you have a fucking Dick.
That's the world that we're going into right now.
And evidently it's like progressive.
It's fucking insane.
It's insane.
Okay.
And right now,
if one of these crazy women listen to this,
they would completely twist what I just said and say that I'm actually against
women who've been abused,
getting some sort of justice,
which is not what I'm saying.
I'm just saying that they're there.
You have to listen to both people and then weigh the evidence.
You know,
even that is a flawed fucking system,
but it's the best system we have.
And now you're going to take that system and you're going to throw it out and
now you just,
you know,
it's like Frankenstein movie that fucking coming up the hill with torches.
Um,
just shut up.
And as you could tell him a little emotional,
you saw it.
Like she had that whole fucking thing planned out.
Like she,
you know,
she thought she was going to get like a bunch of hits,
which I obviously did if I fucking heard about it.
MMM.
Yeah,
I dunno.
It's literally,
it's like McCarthyism meets a fucking myspace is what's going on right now.
Um,
yeah,
yeah.
I should show up and everything works out when we show up to it.
Good.
Me.
Well,
the average guy is driving some sodas shitbox to work,
working for somebody else
in a job that he never really dreamed of having as a kid.
That's most people's fucking reality,
but not on social media.
Okay.
Social media.
Every guys out there running a company eaten steak and lobster for fucking
lunch,
make it as secretary shower is her tits.
Like that's what's happening.
That's what all that and every so every guy out there shut up.
Yeah.
How dare you try to defend yourself and everything.
You worked for a shut up,
do the right thing and chat app.
Um,
just a me,
I can't lay off this shit.
It's so fucking funny that like,
you're literally watching women's reaction to abuse of power and now they have
power and they instantly start abusing it.
Maybe it's just,
it's just completely going off the fucking rails here.
Um,
and most people,
male and female understand that.
But all of us are too afraid to tweet or say fucking anything because then like,
cause then you have to literally apologize.
I watched somebody in my business have to go on an apology tour for literally
having an opinion.
He was an innocent man who hadn't done anything fucking wrong.
He just had an opinion and he had to go out and apologize for having pinion.
Yeah.
And I have an opinion.
You person with a penis and we'll have things you'll want to talk about.
All right.
Felix Gray,
everybody.
Yeah.
The average American blast,
their eyes with bright screens for 11 hours every day.
Oh yeah.
They get go live in the dream,
right.
Staring at a fucking computer.
Um,
now you can protect your eyes with a pair of Felix gray glasses available with
or without a prescription.
I haven't pair of these.
I have a pair of these fucking things and I can tell you they are,
if you,
if you're looking at a computer for a long fucking time and you don't want your
eyes to be doing that little jumping around thing,
this is the solution.
Felix gray glasses filter out 90% of high energy,
blue light and eliminate the glare coming off all of those screens.
That means no more tire,
dry eyes,
blurry vision or headaches.
Usually it seems like a hassle to have to protect your eyes and that's why most
of us don't do it.
But Felix gray glasses aren't like those weird computer glasses.
Um,
you've seen before.
There's no yellow Lens Tint.
I don't even know what the other ones look like.
Felix gray glasses are handcrafted from premium Italian acetate,
Acetate Acetate,
so they won't make you look nerdy.
Acetate is the new fucking,
I dunno,
raw material,
whatever that is.
Is that buried in limestone in shale?
In fact,
throwing on some fee,
Felix Graze is an easy way to look.
Oh,
pretty put together.
this stylish is what the Saint Felix Gray glasses are available in non
prescription prescription and readers with free shipping and free returns.
There's nothing to lose.
Don't go another day.
Looking at screens without the help of Felix Graze.
Go to Felix Gray,
glasses.com f e l I x.
G r a y g.
L a s s e s d o t c o m s l a s H e.
B u.
R.
R,
to protect your eyes today.
That's Felix Gray,
glasses.com/burr.
Hi Felix Gray glasses.com/burb oh,
butcher box stowed.
Fucking get some meat kit.
Yeah.
Do you see those two fucking Boston guys who claimed that they have the
divisional red socks?
Whatever.
A banner.
I Dunno what's,
they either stole that fucking thing or that things fake.
Those things do not just fly off a fucking stadium.
I love how they were like,
you know,
then whole thing sounded like they act like they will get these good guys,
but the whole thing was like a ransom.
Like they had the fucking Lindbergh baby.
Hey,
if you ever worn a fucking shade is ding again.
Now,
then even ask for regular season tickets.
They asked for playoff fucking tickets.
Um,
all right,
put your box.
Do couple of shady characters,
but your box delivers healthy 100% grass fed,
grass finished beef free range,
organic chicken and heritage bread,
pork.
Oh,
the greatest fucking fucking animal you'll ever eat
is a blue blood.
I don't want to be fucking racist here against other pigs.
I don't want to be in the pigs.
A Ku Klux Klan.
And by the way,
it is cool.
It's not cool.
I always thought was Klu Klux Klan,
Ku Klux Klan.
Um,
I don't want to be like the Grand Dragon.
It starts saying separate but equal when it comes to pigs.
But there really is nothing like a heritage breed pork.
All right.
It also,
it did come from Europe,
so this is sounding more fucking pig racist as I go.
But I mean it's unbelievable.
If you haven't been listening to the podcast,
the heritage bread,
pork,
they can drastically traced the bloodline of a pig.
There's actually people out there that do that.
Okay.
What if the woman Yay
fucking shit on it.
Um,
they traced the bloodline
of uh,
these God damn pigs,
purebred pigs,
all the way back to the original pigs.
They came across the fucking Atlantic.
I don't know if they came across with Christopher Columbus.
I Dunno if it was with the Nina,
the Pinta.
And the Santa Maria.
Okay.
It wouldn't surprise me today if some feminist group actually claimed that a
woman's sailed first.
Yeah.
And,
and that nature in wind in general is,
it's much harder for a woman to sail than for a man.
I don't know what happened,
but these fucking pigs came over here and evidently there was so god damn
delicious,
they did not let these pigs breed with the pigs that were already here.
I Dunno what.
So whatever fucking reason,
these things,
these are like,
you know,
these are pure bred,
these,
they're like the,
like the royal family of Pigs,
you know what I mean?
So
they have this amazing bloodline,
but also there's a lot of
breeding,
you know,
so that probably a little crazy.
But the thing is,
is when you get the pork chop,
it's dead so it can't get you.
So I recommend eating these pigs do not have them as pets.
Okay.
Back to the copy.
The incredible quality of butcher box meets stats with a commitment to raising
animals humanely and free of antibiotics and hormones before they murdered them.
Each box comes with at least eight to 11 pounds of meat,
which is enough for 24 individual size meals.
Unless you're a fat fuck or a competitive eater,
you can choose from five different box types.
All beef,
beef and chicken,
beef and pork mixed box.
All right.
I wonder if they let the pure bred go in there.
Mixed Ball.
You should not be mixing to make rat.
God made pork and he made B and they're meant to be chef,
right?
Earl,
will you lock the cross?
All right.
Custom box lets you choose your own cuts.
Personal experience.
I already told you it's the best God damn porkchop I ever had ever except for
one restaurant.
And that was like some chef that was on TV,
but I made a pork chop that would actually make,
I would say would make that chef raised his eyebrow.
Like,
Hey,
that's not even close to what I made,
but I know you're proud of it.
Oh,
taking my nights and I'm going home for $20 off your first box in two pounds of
free ground beef and every box for the life of your subscription.
Um,
that's $20 off your first box and two pounds of free meat a month.
And for P,
that's a lot of fucking meat.
And for people who already are butcher box subscribers,
you'll have a special deal on ground beef you can take advantage of by law
logging into your account.
Go to butcher box.com/burn at the pro.
Enter the Promo Code [inaudible] at checkout.
Once again,
put your box.com/burr and enter burr at checkout.
All right,
hallux sleep.
He links.
Okay.
There's nobody on the planet like you.
You're age 23 to 38.
You're a millennial.
Why should you just have a standard bed like generation y,
generation x baby boomers,
the greatest generation,
the lost generation,
the knickers generation.
Um,
I said knickers,
by the way,
as in pants before I get in trouble.
Like sleep everybody.
There's nobody on the planet like you.
So why would you buy a generic mattress built for everyone else?
Please mention the talking points below.
Of course I will.
He likes sleep hallux matches your body to the mattress so you get the best
sleep of your life.
It doesn't matter if you have back fat,
if you have man tits,
if you have a crooked nose.
Okay.
I,
I'm guessing they pour you into some sort of a mold or the love of the mattress
molds to you.
It's like the dental impressions I used to take back in the day,
except it's the mattress version.
They've developed nine different mattresses tailored to specific body types and
sleep preferences.
So evidently there's nobody like you till you get to that 10th person,
but it's still pretty cool though.
You know,
just go to the Helix,
sleeping alex.com/bird take their two minutes sleep quiz and they'll match you
to them as fucking hilarious,
which ways it hang and bloody and they'll match you to a mattress that's perfect
for you,
contouring to your body to provide unprecedented comfort and better sleep.
Do you have cankles?
How would you describe your ass if it was a balloon?
Is it losing air?
Does it not have it?
Did somebody step on it?
36% of Helix sleep customers report better sleep after switching to their
customized mattress from helix sleep.
Alex.
Right now they're offering up to $125 off all mattress orders.
Whether you're aside
a hot sleeper,
Jesus Christ,
whether you're a thrasher,
whether you're trying to kick,
kick smack,
whatever you got,
man,
like a plush toy,
like a plush or affirm bread bed,
they've got the mattress that will fit just right.
If you've got a body buried in the back yard,
you know,
I don't know.
You're fucking thinking.
No.
The tell tale heart,
they got that mattress for you.
Get up to $125 off Felix,
sleep.com/bar hallux.
That's helix.
How it's he likes sleep.com/per $425 off your mattress order.
He likes sleep.com/burr hallux.
All right,
I believe that's all I have to read.
Um,
oh,
okay.
I read,
I can't read all the right ones.
Okay,
there you go.
And I want to just tell,
I just want to thank all the brave women out there who are podcasting.
I know it's so much more difficult for you to turn on the power button than it
is for a man.
And I'm really looking at myself right now and I'm reflecting on the,
the privilege that I've enjoyed as a podcaster simply because of my genitalia.
Um,
today I will go out into the world knowing that and adjusting my behavior
accordingly.
Women,
you have no work to do when it comes to how you treat men just can just stay the
fucking course and uh,
keep telling everybody how difficult you fucking lives are when there's like,
what,
like six holidays a year.
That is specifically people how late they
hype mother's Day versus Father's Day.
You know,
there's all kinds of flowers canny get and show your much,
am I right?
Father's Day,
your dad,
he's going to die first.
You know what I mean?
So this should be more of a sense of urgency.
Wouldn't you think that?
No.
Yeah.
Get him a fucking tie.
What's,
he can fucking hang himself while he's jerking off in the closet.
All right.
That's,
that's the podcast.
Yeah.
Ladies and gentlemen,
got to make sure I said ladies first,
because they have,
it's so much harder.
Everything,
you know,
just,
just them breathing.
You know,
air is more difficult on female lungs.
Um,
and it's been proven.
please enjoy this music
and then we're going to do a little,
uh,
what do you call it?
They're a little fucking,
a little throwback to the,
uh,
to the blow back there to the law.
It's a Thursday afternoon podcast and it will be an extra half an hour of
greatest hits Thursday afternoon,
just before Monday,
just for Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
That's what it's all right.
Have a wonderful weekend.
You can't,
and go fuck yourselves and I'll,
uh,
talk to you on Monday.
Wait,
he's trying to,
you know,
I know it's going to be a tough weekend for you.
You know,
my weekend's going to be way easier to just,
you know,
try to keep your head,
try to keep your heads up.
[inaudible]
right on the bat.
This sounds fucking creepy to me.
Video Doorbell.
Uh,
we'll insert dinging sound.
What does that mean?
I was supposed to fucking insert ding.
Dongs all right,
let's do it again.
Uh,
I can do this.
Here we go.
Doorbell
sound.
This is like Donald Trump announcing he's running for president doorbells.
Sound effect.
Okay.
Did you meet doorbell?
All one word.
Of course I did.
Okay.
Let's see if I can do this correctly.
All right.
Hey everybody.
Video Doorbell.
Let's do that again.
Oh,
I'm at an all of layers to the podcast
here.
Hang on a second.
It's got a fucking,
uh,
it's got reload here.
Hey everybody.
I'd like to take a little bit of time to talk about it.
Video Doorbell.
What is really odd?
I was the shit video doorbell.
This is the sound of a package being delivered or friends coming over for
dinner,
but it's also the sound of summing plant.
Someone planning to rob you,
blind Jesus Christ.
That took a left turn.
Then it over 90,
95% of home break ins happened during the day and I write the way.
Is it?
What's going on here?
Oh,
I think I'm stuck in one of those youtube loops where they just keep playing the
fucking the doorbell.
Well,
I think it works with the copy.
I'm going to keep it anyways.
And burglars always almost always start by ringing the doorbell to see if
someone's home before pillaging your possession.
I guess that's a fancier doorbell.
Oh,
I like this music too with ring video doorbell.
You can see and talk to anyone
from anywhere in the world using your smartphone.
Hi,
I'm bill her.
What's happening?
Is this a DJ party?
MMM.
Okay.
I think we're having a fire alert here.
Back to the copy rings.
Advanced motion detection alerts you,
even if someone doesn't ring the doorbell,
it's like a caller id for your home.
You know,
millions of people suffer every year and they don't have a video doorbell.
Please share a personal story how this could help you or someone you love.
Hey,
will you share a pocket personal story?
It isn't enough.
I'm reading your copy.
I don't know anybody who has a video fucking doorbell.
How does that work for you and your story?
You'll get another one.
I'm sorry.
It's sealing ring takes minutes and it works with either your current wiring or
built in rechargeable battery.
Put your mind at ease and protect your home and your Perry keyed with the video
doorbell Time magazine named one of the top 10 gadgets of 2014 Sharon and
Kilmore porpoises cause eventually you'd have to throw out the wires and they
will end up in the ocean.
But right now my listeners get the ring video doorbell for only $174.
That's $25 off the normal price.
Still kind of expensive though.
You know
your fucking house comes with the doorbell already attached.
He's still making payments.
Anyways,
go to ring.com/burnout protect your home and@peaceofmindwithgotoring.com slash
square for $25 off.
Once again,
it's [inaudible] dot com slash book
okay.
Oh and he fades off the music.
Jesus Christ.
That could be a DJ,
but a fucking mouse had on me and see what happens.
I'll tell you what will happen,
Huh?
Bunch of drugs will be taken.
Um,
how much can I freak out people that one of those Raves,
if you just had the DJ and he's clean,
all this mellow shit,
then all of a sudden out of nowhere,
I just started coming out with a mouse head screaming cunt over and over again.
Yeah,
I would love to have an overhead shot of that.
You know,
maybe use one of those drones and just watching him all scatter like fucking
roaches all across the desert.
Stepping on sidewinders
[inaudible]
going on.
It's Belper,
right?
It is the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
September 20th,
2010 and I am doing this really late.
I apologize everybody a head,
a Baru till day.
I had a brutal Dan.
It had nothing to do with my patriots getting their fucking asses.
Hand a tool by the Goddamn jets.
Congratulations.
All you green countries out there in the metal lands.
Stick your chest out.
I'm sure you're happy.
I'm sure you're proud.
You know,
you know what sucks about it is the jets game the week before the one that I
predicted that I was fucking dead on right about that the ravens were going to
win,
happened on a Monday night.
I had already recorded my podcast so I didn't get to talk Shit and pat myself on
the fucking back about it.
By the time I did the jets bounce back and a kick the shit out of the Patriots
and a,
I will say this about it.
I actually recorded a podcast yesterday before the jets game cause I wanted to
talk shit about it and give my prediction.
But um,
I actually ended up being dead on in my own way,
but I didn't think anybody was really going to believe it.
But then some of them reminded me that I actually did call.
I said take the jets and the points.
I did a thing on the versus network,
uh,
this past week and I trashed the jets as I always do because uh,
I'm from Boston and I fucking hate the New York teams.
I respect your city.
It's lovely,
especially in the fall,
walking through central park with the leaves crunching under your shoes.
Who doesn't like to do that?
Wonderful,
wonderful museums.
You know,
a rare good slice of pizza.
I will tell you that only because New York is known for its pizza that uh,
so many fucking assholes who can't make pizza have sprung up and they all say
that they're famous.
I've said this shit before.
Just start to,
you know,
any New Yorkers want to tell the tourists where to go.
Cause I got no huge argument about some fucking brought Eaton cunt from Chicago
who said New York pizza sucks.
I mean granted he enjoys their Lasagna,
whatever the fuck they call their pizza out there.
And if you're from Chicago,
tell me where to get the good deep dish because the shit I get out there,
it's like even if you get the personal sized one,
it's like you feel like you ate a birthday cake made out of spaghetti sauce,
but by the time you're done with it,
it's that level of full where you want to kill yourself and it doesn't really
taste that good.
But I know there's no way that there's not a great spot in Chicago.
So Chicago and New York have your pizza war.
Tell me where to go.
But anyways,
um,
this is what I felt about the game was basically my heart.
I have to go with the Patriots,
but I just had that bad failing cause I have this theory on divisional rivalries
is that they never go the way they go.
If I could remember the name of the God damn show I was on,
on the versus network,
that's really bad too because I had a great time and they will like,
yeah,
come back anytime.
I can't remember the name of the fucking show cause that's how I operate.
I go in there totally in just go in and fucking kill mode.
That,
so to the point that I don't even fucking,
I remembered the channel that's new for me.
I just did a fuck load of media and it had something had something me the line
in it.
I can't remember what the fourth at Nightline.
I know it wasn't that,
but uh,
I was actually right two fucking weeks in a row.
That's what's killing me now.
This is not me break down the game.
This is what,
uh,
this is what I didn't like was the,
the Patriots' defense took a big step backwards and they look like the hapless
crew from last fucking year.
But I'm also smart enough to realize that week two does not define a fucking
season.
But,
uh,
I gotta be honest.
Uh,
I don't know.
I was like it Hernandez,
that guy look great.
And I think Tom Brady was being really generous when he said that,
uh,
we couldn't do anything right in the second half.
It's like,
dude,
how about after the first quarter?
I mean,
I guess we went down and we went up 14 fucking seven,
but then they march right back down the field.
But anyways,
hopefully I am,
I am converting some people to my way of looking at sports,
which is last week doesn't mean shit.
I mean,
you gotta you gotta like do like whatever the jets did either being anemic or
kicking the shit out of somebody.
You gotta do it like three,
four weeks in a row before you can get excited.
You know,
but I mean you just watched these analysts on TV and it's like whatever somebody
just did is who the fuck they are.
And uh,
did I say it last week on the podcast,
how the paths that led up 350 yards,
150 fucking yards to old say I didn't like those numbers.
I did not like those numbers,
but I still,
I thought it was going to be one of those cunty 19 to 17 games.
And I thought in the end I was praying that we were going to come out and get a
victory,
but I did not,
I did not think that we were going to get,
we were going to get pounded and we got,
we got pounded in a very light way.
I don't remember any sort of big hit other than the big hit in the end for the
fumble.
But it was just sort of,
I just felt like we were in a prevent defense from the second quarter.
Ron,
you know,
ah,
just,
you know,
you deal with that zone.
Let people go.
And I have to admit that fucking Revus guy really pissed me off when he got
burned for a touchdown and then grabs his Hami.
Can I do that from now on?
When I fuck up in life,
I'm sitting there talking all kinds of shit and I'm killing for 20 minutes with
jokes.
And then I tell one that bombs and then I just,
I started grabbing my hamstring and I fucking,
you know,
lay down and have somebody stretch it out.
That was a really fucking bitch move.
And I don't buy it.
I don't buy the whole goddamn story.
I don't like how before the game even started,
Reavis already had a fucking excuse.
I think he was scared from the week before.
Not that he's bad,
the guy's the shit.
But I think he was out of shape and he was worried that a Randy Moss was going
to run all over his island.
That's so fucking gave Reavis island,
you know,
who would ever go there.
But you're fucking guys standing around squatting down
and that quarterback fucking position,
you know,
I dunno.
Speaking of that,
speaking a gay,
here's an email I got recently from a gay guy,
a,
believe it or not,
I have,
I have all kinds of fans on this.
You wouldn't know this from some of those fucking assholes up in Seattle who
branded me a homophobe because they listened to the first half of the way you
were fig bit and stomped off like the fucking pansies that they were.
Here's a guy right here.
All right.
Said bill watched.
Let it go last night.
Uh,
and it was fantastic.
Congratulations.
Uh,
that's hilarious.
Um,
no,
you know what's hilarious was I was thinking let it go as my last special and
why the hell did in my head,
I immediately pictured my,
uh,
why do I do this anyway?
So I'm an idiot.
Let me start over.
Watch,
let it go last night.
It was fantastic.
Congratulations.
It was kind of cool to hear some of the things you had talked about in the
podcast turns into developed bits.
I was wondering if you brought stuff from the stage to podcast or is it vice
versa?
Do you use the podcast to develop bits?
I was also wondering how much input,
uh,
you are other comics have on editing on the editing of your specials.
I've noticed that your recent special is lit differently.
Better in my opinion than many comedy central specials.
The audience is dark and there is a nice spotlight on you instead of the whole
stage being lit.
How did you get that deal?
Also,
the commercial breaks seem to come at strange places.
Did you get to decide where they went?
Sorry for all the questions.
Bottom line is the special.
It was amazing.
The podcast is great and I'm a huge fan.
Well thank you very much.
Then he said,
ps,
you look great and better and better as you age.
Does that seem gay for one man to say to another?
Well guess what bill?
I am gay.
Deal with it.
Ah,
that's fucking awesome.
All right,
great questions.
They are twinkle toes.
All right.
What do we got here?
The first one he asked,
he said a watch,
let it go.
Less than it was fitted into the,
Oh,
you're wondering if do I take stuff from the podcasts and take it to the stage
and vice versa?
Uh,
there's a little bit of both,
but definitely more podcasts to the stage.
I try not to burn bits on the podcast where it's like if I actually did a bit
from my act,
then you come and see me.
It's already kind of a finished thing,
then I would feel like I was fucking you over.
But there's definitely times when I riff on stuff that a little light goes off
on my head and I'm like,
you know what,
that's really funny.
And I think that I could take that somewhere.
But even then,
even if you heard it on the podcast,
it,
I don't say it the way it's set on the podcast,
it like continues,
you know what I mean?
Kind of like when Stevie Ray Vaughn did his cover of a say what Jimmy Hendricks,
which was,
wasn't that like two things,
splice tape together?
I can't remember.
What does that rainy day?
He did,
he did a cover up and he just sort of took the beginning riff.
That's right.
Yeah.
He took the beginning ref for that and then he just sort of fleshed out the
middle and added his whole type of shit to it.
So I tried to do that with like,
did I just bring up Stevie Ray Vaughn and Jimmy Hendricks?
I'm sorry.
Sorry.
My fucking Egos really pumped up with all the great emails you guys sent me
about my special last night.
But yes,
to answer your question,
um,
occasionally shit like that does go to the stage,
but I'm really sensitive about that because I don't like people,
I wouldn't want someone to come to me and be like,
dude,
it was,
it was everything he said on the,
as I,
you know,
I don't mind if somebody comes up and says like,
yeah,
that was something I heard in the podcast and then you,
you took it in this other area.
Like,
listen,
I'm just fucking meandering right now.
You can't do that on a standup states.
People will be throwing like fucking potato skins at me.
So,
um,
that's the deal.
And if I ever do an old debt from my act,
I actually just say it.
This is a bit I used to do and I usually do an abridged version.
So there we go.
All right,
next one.
Uh,
I was also wondering how much input you had,
uh,
on the editing of your specials.
Um,
that's a huge thing that I have input on and from why do I do this and let it go
is there is a specific look that I want and as specific vibe that I am looking
for and that,
and it's very important to me and I think it's even more important than the
fucking material if you can believe it just because I have seen some
unbelievable comedians with shitty production and it knocks down the level of
your performance and that sucks because it's not your fault.
So you really have to like,
I've learned that just through like the,
the few TV movie things that I've done,
like as far as editing,
lighting,
all those fucking guys,
the sound,
all of those guys,
director,
it's like they can take a mediocre performance and make it look fucking
unbelievable and they can take an,
um,
an amazing performance and make it look like cannonball run part two if they
don't know what the fuck they're doing.
So,
uh,
so there you go.
There's my big shout out to art and industry who's done my last two specials and
we'll continue doing my specials cause they do a great fucking job.
Uh,
I basically tell them exactly what I'm looking for and I always come at him with
shit that has nothing to do with comedy.
They'll just be like,
what do you want it to look like?
I'm like,
you ever see the magnificent seven when they're fucking sitting there eating
those Rancharrah Huevos whatever the fuck you say it.
Um,
I come at them like that.
so there you go.
Great.
Kept great question right out of the God damn gate.
Um,
but anyways,
let's continue on.
Uh,
talking a little football here.
Um,
how about those fucking bears?
Huh?
I didn't know that Mike Martz is,
uh,
is their offensive coordinator.
They all of a sudden overnight got a little scary and like I said,
I'm not judging them on two weeks.
I mean they basically lost to the fucking lines and then we're given that
victory.
My apology to lions fans last week cause I was going like,
look at you guys,
you're playing competitive.
I had not seen the highlight of how you got fucked out of that game.
Um,
but like that is a devastating combination cause Mike Martz is,
is like right in his fucking wheel wheel house.
You know what I mean?
It's like how Deniro was doing comedy and meet the parents and all that shit.
But all of a sudden if,
if they go back to doing the good fellas shit,
he's right.
He's debts.
He's fucking in it.
So,
okay.
I Dunno man.
That's,
that's,
that's the big thing.
You got to have all the fucking pieces you get out of the ownership.
You have to have the coaches and you have to have the players.
It's like,
what that fucking Matt Cassel I remember by my buddy of mine was giving me Shit
when we traded him for a first round fucking draft pick or whatever to the
chiefs and he was like,
dude,
I mean the guy looked at him.
He went 11 and five and then all those fucking pieces,
all those people who are trying to give Brady Shit because Brady was hurting
yet the Patriots win 11 and five typical fantasy football,
fucking morons.
They don't realize that Mac castle was driving a Lamborghini that year.
He was driving a team throughout the regular season that went 16 and older when
every fucking game and what did he,
he managed the fucking game and gave us five less fucking victories,
but then people's heads and like 11 and five man,
okay,
that's fucking nuts.
If he goes to Kansas City and does what it does,
what
drives that fucking 1972 eco liner that is the Kansas City chiefs.
Now all of a sudden,
right?
You're fucking need a fuel pump.
That timing belt snaps and right there,
Matt Cassel looks like he should be holding a fucking clipboard again.
Is it his fault?
I don't fucking think so.
But you got to have everybody.
So that's my point.
Dot.
The fucking Chicago bears haven't,
what's his face,
Mike?
March.
Whenever the hell his God damn name is.
I can't even think at this point.
I'm so sick of fucking talking after a week of press last week.
Um,
okay.
Having those two guys is huge,
is fucking huge.
And all of a sudden Jay Cutler looks like a good Goddamn quarterback,
doesn't he?
Doesn't he?
So with that,
how about some predictions?
I got to talk shit early.
Paths are playing again next Sunday.
Which Patriot team is going to show up,
you know,
according to him,
according to my stats,
the exact same fucking defense showed up both fucking weeks.
God dammit.
Our defense stinks.
We're not going to win shit without,
you know,
something that's actually a
great,
uh,
I think it because I never felt like the patriots players ever got their fucking
do when we were winning those championships.
Dad,
you're a mediocre team with no superstars.
Now all of a sudden I have to,
I don't.
You look at Teddy Bruschi and [inaudible] and all those guys in a different
light.
Okay.
Maybe you don't,
I don't fucking know.
What do we got?
Let me talk one thing.
New Orleans at San Francisco,
there's another divisional rivalry game.
I don't like it.
Everybody's saying New Orleans is going to run all over them.
I think it's going to be closer than that just because they were in the same
fucking division.
Those games are always cunty.
All right.
Week three buffalo at New England.
Ah,
oh gee.
I want to say we're going to bounce back,
but I mean I don't,
fuck,
I don't fucking know it.
That defense.
You know what it is about the pets.
We have no pass rush.
All right.
Jet Fans before we get all excited about Sanchez sitting back at a fucking lazy
boy in the pocket.
That son of a bitch can scramble though.
I will give you that.
But who did the jet tab next week?
Who Do they get?
Who they get?
Are you guys talking shit again?
Oh,
Jetson Miami.
Miami's gonna beat Ya man.
He's got a fucking insane defense.
You're going to go on the road.
All right.
I think.
What's his face?
Rex?
Ryan's going to poke his head out of the shelf.
He's gonna Start Talking Shit.
It's going to look at,
get a little drunk and get sunburned.
Fall Asleep on the fucking beach.
He's going,
he's going to be miserable down there.
I have no idea.
But I'm telling you right now,
they are fucking jet fans before your hoist a fireman up on your shoulder like
you're doing the village people fucking act,
uh,
don't sleep on Miami.
You don't like about Miami.
Their coach looks like he's in the fucking witness protection program.
The fuck is with that guy.
I watched that game and they kept cutting to him on the sidelines and I have no
fucking idea what he looks like.
He's got a baseball hat yanked down to his huge fucking Tony Curtis sunglasses.
He's got that big,
uh,
who's that guy from the big Lebowski?
Oh,
does the narration.
Whenever the guy from mask,
he's got one of those fucking,
I own a Harley musty.
I have no fucking idea what he looks like.
And then green bay in Chicago.
That's a great Monday.
And I came.
All right,
I have to get back to the podcast here because I know a lot of people are,
are uh,
not sports fans.
So let me tell you about my week.
Everybody.
Um,
leading up to my special was I went to New York City and I did the open Anthony
Program.
Wonderful Program.
If for some reason you live in a cave and you've never heard of it,
it's a,
a sort of a political show.
Um,
a lot of topics are discussed.
I'm actually,
I obviously I'm fucking around.
It's over the top and I got to tell you,
Jim Norton had the funniest God damn joke that I don't even think got the laugh
it deserved.
It was so funny.
It actually made me a better person and I'm going to tell you why I was fucking
opiate mentioned he was trying to sign something and he said that they wouldn't
let him sign it with like a pen to paper.
He had to do this virtual signing or whatever.
That's computer thing.
So me being the shithead than I am immediately jump into a connecting the dots
that this is this big conspiracy that they want to have this computer.
Um,
I dunno,
something like I can't see,
I'm so stupid.
I can't even see,
I can't even say how the fuck am I trying to say here.
They basically,
then they have it,
they have basically your signature like on a stamp,
but it's in like computer form and they go and that's for the Illuminati.
And then later on five years,
if you don't like what they're doing,
they'll just take out the Amaa
Nazi document and it just puts your computer signature right underneath it.
That's what they're going to do.
And then Jim just goes,
or the Illuminati could just forge your signature.
Uh,
I butchered it.
It was fucking great.
And it really just made me feel like,
exactly,
Bill.
Exactly.
You know,
why don't you just fucking relax if they're really that powerful,
do they really need to create schemes to that fucking level?
And a,
I have to tell you,
I,
I must've thought about that line maybe 50 fucking times.
I've just been walking around thinking my crazy thoughts and then that joke,
his voice keeps popping in my head going,
oh,
the Illuminati could just forge your signature.
And it just makes me laugh at what a fucking ridiculous human being I am.
Um,
so there you go.
Shout out out to
Jimmy Norton there.
Um,
but anyways,
so this is my week.
So I did the opening of the program.
I did,
uh,
I did the versus network,
had a great time on that.
And hopefully we'll be doing more shit on that.
I also did a Nesson where I talked all kinds of shit about the jets.
I had fun on that one cause that was just in Boston.
So I was able to,
I didn't have to bleed the diplomatic on that one.
And a,
when I left I did Pete Dominick show,
I did a Jim Breuer show.
All those guys just Warren's thank say thank you to everybody who let me run my
mouth and a hype my special and thanks to everybody who watched it and uh,
sent me all the great emails and everything.
And uh,
and with that,
if you'd like to buy it,
go to amazon.com you can actually,
the presale I think,
is it still the presale price?
I don't know.
It was like 13,
26.
Uh,
if you want to buy it for that cheap amount and then bring it to one of my
shows,
I'll fucking sign it for you.
I don't give a shit.
Just go ahead and buy it.
And I would really appreciate it if you guys would go out and buy it because
believe it or not,
it really does help me as a performer if you do things like that.
And uh,
one of the things I've noticed being a huge music fan is I go on,
um,
I go on youtube and I'm always watching,
you know,
like clips of bands and shit like that.
And one of the things that people keep asking is they say,
where is all the talent?
You know what I mean?
Like where are the Beatles were the stones where,
where are the,
uh,
the Marvin Gaye's where all these fucking people,
and I have this theory,
granted Jim Norton might take the fucking piss out of this one too with one of
his fucking life,
great lines,
but it's this same people asking these questions of the people not paying for
music and a decade of trying to have your cake and eat it.
Basically the music industry doesn't exist anymore.
And for his dirty and filthy as those sons of bitches were,
there were just like,
there's good and bad comics.
Their word genius guys in that industry.
And they knew they could spot talent and they knew how to develop it and nurture
it before they put it out there and that type of stuff.
And then of course then they would steal from him.
Um,
but like that system doesn't fucking exist anymore.
And,
uh,
my business,
it's going the same route where TV,
film,
Dvds and all those are not being paid for and,
uh,
people are losing their jobs and that type of shit.
So I dunno if you like comedy,
if you like good television,
I suggest trying to not saying don't watch reality shows.
I would be fucking hypocrite right now cause I love the Jersey shore.
I really haven't watched season
into,
but I watched the Jersey shore,
but like,
I still try to watch scripted shows.
I pay for movies,
I don't steal movies.
I pay for all my fucking music.
And uh,
I dunno,
if you don't give a fuck,
then just by all means go ahead and steal it.
But if,
if you're one of those people
wondering where all the great bands are,
where the great writers are,
and they don't have have
jobs right now,
they don't because you can sit on a toilet and take a shit.
Don't sit in on a toilet sitting on a toilet,
sitting on the toilet.
You can do that and you'll get for some reason a zillion fucking hits.
And,
uh,
I dunno,
I don't even know what my fucking point is.
Just for the love of God.
Can you buy the Goddamn DVD?
All right.
$13 26 cents so he can pick it up.
Fucking 20 bucks at one of my shows.
I'll sign it for you.
Take a picture,
give you a Goddamn hug,
whatever the fuck you need.
But for Christ's sake,
can,
can you support my God damn career?
That's all I'm asking you.
All right,
look,
I go on youtube too.
All right.
I'm just,
I'm not saying,
you know,
I mean,
I go there,
I look at Shit and I'm looking at Shit for free.
I realize that.
But the shit that I really like,
I do pay for it,
but I pay for all my fucking music.
All right.
God dammit.
You know what's funny is most of you are probably going to go out and buy my DVD
and I just basically did what the fuck and Catholic priests would do when I was
growing up when they would basically yell at the people who showed up for
church.
So with that,
let's give you some funny youtube clips and you can watch all of these right in
a row.
Conveniently on the uh,
the EMM podcast.com the official fan page of the Monday morning podcast.
And I want to thank all the listeners,
uh,
who go onto that and left all those great messages about them going out there
trying to get the word out.
I'm telling you,
even though you know it,
it helps out.
You have no fucking idea how much that helps me out due to the fact that there's
500 channels.
Now there's the internet,
there's video games,
there's people with cameras making videos for fucking youtube.
There's just so much shit out there.
There's Tivo and all that like you guys doing that really,
really helped me.
So I just want to say thank you.
Okay.
This is really a feel good podcast.
You would never know that my team got trounced by the team that I've been
trashing.
Oh,
by the way,
all the jets and apology.
Um,
I'm not the part where I say they're not going to win the Superbowl and I,
I won't apologize for that.
After week two,
um,
but the fact that I actually suggested that they still play a giant stadium and
that they sub leaded their stadium from,
uh,
from the giants,
they don't now,
now they co own it with the giants.
So the jet's got a little more credibility in the giants became a little more
pathetic,
but they can spin it and just say that what they're doing is a very green thing
to do.
It's great for the environment.
But,
but considering,
uh,
the jets,
their colors are green,
I still think that they come out on top.
So a what do you going to say about that?
Um,
I miss the game last night where Peyton beat the shit out of his little brother.
Like all big brothers should do.
I haven't tell you that.
If you have a younger brother,
at no point in your life,
can you ever lose to him in anything ever.
Yeah.
No.
I mean know he can get a better fucking job,
Marissa,
hotter woman that can fucking happen.
But I'm talking about shit that really counts like sports wrestling and are in a
real fight.
You can never fucking loose.
And if they,
even if he beats you in a fight,
what you do is you just turn that into a round and as you collect yourself,
you grabbed something to beat them over the head with and then you win round
two.
I know the ladies out there probably don't understand that,
but anybody with a younger brother,
I'm telling you,
I never lost to any of my younger brothers.
I am undefeated in fights undefeated.
And if I said that right now,
considering we're all about the same size,
I would have a couple of fights on my card,
but,
uh,
hopefully no one in my family listens to this.
All right,
let's get out to the youtube videos for the week.
All right.
Your sons a bitches.
Um,
all of these are available on the [inaudible] podcast.com.
You can watch them right in a row.
All right.
This is one of my favorite videos I've seen in a while.
It's called Macho Salad,
m a,
c h o o Macho Salad.
And this is just a great piece of acting from a,
I don't know what movie this is.
I believe that they speaking German,
I can't fucking remember.
But this guy wants to get laid and is his girl tells him,
you know,
she's not in the mood.
This is what I'm guessing from the dialogue and tells him to go make a salad.
And this son of a bitch makes a fucking salad and a,
it's awesome.
It's just like,
it's just one of those things where I don't know how many takes this guy had to
do,
but uh,
it's,
it's the shit and I aspire to someday be to do something like that.
Acting.
All right.
Um,
the next thing we got here,
uh,
this,
this video actually made me so upset.
You have a watch,
a youtube video and you wished that you could just somehow step into your screen
and fucking go into the video and just basically inflict your view of what the
justice should have been.
No.
Well,
okay.
The watch this video,
it's actually a clip from the doctor Phil Show.
You know that crooked cop looking dude who pretends he's a psychologist but he's
really just a fucking therapist who wanted to have groupies so we can get some
more pussy on the side and realize that he wasn't going to get it in a fucking
therapy room.
So he was like,
I know I'll do a TV show and say Avi is shit slowly.
Uh,
anyways,
let's continue.
Uh,
he has a clip on there.
It's the name of this video is called fat kid slaps mum.
Mum.
All right.
And just to set this one up,
this is basically obviously a mother who can't control her kid.
He's a fat kid.
He's about 11 or 12 his voice hasn't changed yet and he's sitting there sitting
down across from his mother who is also sitting down and nose to nose.
They are having discussion and this kid is taking his mother to task,
interrupting her and then when she gives him shit for interrupting her,
he goes,
well how does that feel?
How does that,
how do you like it?
Like completely out of fucking control and this kid's got this temper and he's
so fucking out of line in and she starts giving him shit and out of nowhere he
just hauls off and fucking slaps her like a God damn pimp.
You only need the one.
The only reason why it wasn't a pimp slap it cause it wasn't a backhand but it
had the same fucking,
it sounded like a flare chop right to her fucking cheek.
And there's this pause and I'm like,
oh my God,
she is going to be on him like a mountain lion.
And I'm going to see the boom mic guide jumping in,
trying to pull her off from clogging the eyes out of this kids fucking head.
There's that pause and then the kid just goes,
how does that feel?
How do you like it?
And the mother does absolutely nothing.
And I swear to God,
I was just like,
I had to like stand up and like walk around and do like little circles.
You know when you want to walk away from the video,
but you have to watch it again.
So you just do those little fucking figure eights.
I was like,
you gotta you gotta be fucking kidding me.
Why aren't you fucking chilling that Shit right now?
Right.
And I,
you know what I would've done if I was that,
if I was at,
I just wanted to answer.
I just really,
I was scaring my dog over there.
Sorry,
Dude.
Sorry about that.
All right.
We're just acting over here.
Everything's good,
man.
Everything's good.
Yeah.
Cleo,
dod.
Oh,
sorry.
Um,
what does it take to make a dog's fucking wag its tail?
It takes literally two seconds.
Um,
anyways,
I just looked at that video and I was,
I immediately just imagine being married to that woman.
And then that was my son and I was
okay.
I gotta tell you right now,
if,
you know,
when I married mia and we have kids and do all that shit,
if one of our kids ever slaps her in the face,
I will.
I would've,
yeah,
I would've fucking throat.
I want to choke slam that kid through the fucking coffee table with any luck.
It would be one of those old school and tea coffee tables,
you know,
that were made out of the really good wood from deepen the fucking forest,
not that Ikea Shit that explodes like a fucking stunt table,
you know?
And I would just put that mother fucker right through it and then I would pull
him up by his goddamn larynx and then right through the fucking dry wall.
All right.
My hand would be disappearing into the wall.
Like I just fist it a fucking horse.
And you would be wondering where that kid was.
And then I pull them out and he'd have all that fucking plaster in his hair and
he'd start to cry and then I would just fucking take away like three quarters of
his oxygen and I would whisper in his ear really calmly,
like one of those bad guys in those great eighties movies with Mel Gibson.
Well,
once they get them tied up
or a fucking Stallone or whatever,
all the fucking,
the goons would get in tied up.
And then the,
the,
the real,
the head bad guy who's running shit would just come in all relaxed with his
fucking dress shoes and suit and we just come up and just sort of put his face
like parallel to the other dude's face.
You know,
you just come in,
you just whisper and right in the guy's ear.
Nice and calmly.
That's what I would do to him has this kid was struggling to breathe.
I just put my fucking head right next to his ear and I would just be like,
if you ever slap your mother in the face again,
I will fucking kill you.
If you want to stay in me,
do you understand me?
The only reason why you're not dead right now is because I haven't figured out
how to get away with it yet.
I'd be saying shit like that,
and then you go upstairs and you go to your fucking room.
If you even look at her over the next month,
I swear to God,
I will grab you by your fucking baby fat and the top of your fucking head.
I will throw you upside down through the fucking bay window.
Do you understand that?
As you sit out there in the rain,
picking the glass in the woods,
shards out of your body?
I'm going to take a tray,
a hot macaroni and throw it right on your fucking face.
That's what I'm going to do.
If you ever fucking touch your mother again,
was that a little too violent?
Was it?
Well,
I don't give a fuck.
All right.
That's how I came up.
You know,
I grew up,
if I,
if I actually,
the reason why I expected that woman to claw their kid's eyes out,
cause that's where my mom would have done.
My mom did not need a father figure
hanging around the Goddamn House.
Basically.
If,
if that woman was my mother,
the only role the dad would have would be at some point to pull the mom off that
kid in order to fucking say,
my mother would have just grabbed the nearest,
she would have fucked it off.
Remember old school moms,
they've drew blood,
they will like cats and they just fucking disease dug their nails into you and
they grabbed you and really weird places.
They would just grab like a handful of neck somehow have your judge
killer in there and
they do that.
And then the other hand,
like the thumb would somehow get into this party.
Your armpit you didn't even know existed and they would just take a chunk of
flesh out of that somehow there'd be no holes in your fucking tee shirt and they
would just stay with it was unbelievable.
So like a fucking Scifi movie.
When you were done and you,
you fucked a went upstairs and your skin was just burning from wherever the fuck
they had.
Claude you when you took it looked like,
yeah,
like he got a by a bobcat.
Yeah,
right.
To do those moms exist anymore?
We,
I dunno,
date,
I think there's been an overcorrection and one time one of my brothers said that
I kicked him in the face,
which was bullshit.
I kicked him in the stomach,
which was considered legal and working it out amongst yourselves.
My mother was brushing her hair.
She was late for work.
She had to,
she had to go with frontier justice.
She didn't have time for my side of the story.
She just turned around and she went to smash this thing over my head,
like a fucking gavel.
So I did.
Basically,
I did this defensive move where I ducked,
but not like a man.
I didn't do like the boxing,
like fucking come up and under and then fucking with the right hook.
I didn't do that shit.
What I basically did was I immediately did a fucking 180 so now I wasn't facing
my mother.
I put my shoulders up to my ears,
I bent over slightly at a 45 degree angle and then for some reason I made my
arms go a little,
my elbows go a little past my back and I,
I I squinted eye look like Pau Gasol before right before he decides to go to the
rack,
anticipating the foul.
And Luckily I enough,
she missed
my head and just hit me right in the back.
Like I took one of those folding chairs and rustling from Pat Patterson right to
my fucking back and I went down and a God damn heap in landed on that Kmart
fucking bath mat is the shards of the plastic brush just landed all around me.
You know what my mother's big concern was,
was that she broke her brush,
you know,
and it was old school back then when you didn't have flat screen TVs and when
you're broke a brush,
if,
if the rubber part with the bristles still existed,
she just continue using it.
And she did for years.
She just,
she just hit rather than having a handle and fucking combing it,
like brushing it like Barbie,
she just held it in her hand now like you know those brushes black guys use when
they try to get waves in their hair.
That's what it looked like.
And she just kept using that and every time I saw it I was reminded of that.
And it was like a week later that the two of us,
we just started laughing about it like,
mom,
when are you going to buy a new brush?
And she said,
well,
there's nothing wrong with this one.
There's nothing wrong with it.
It doesn't fucking three quarters of it doesn't even exist anymore.
And isn't it a fucking reminder that you smash the rest of it over it over one
of your kids' backs?
No,
she didn't give a fuck and she shouldn't have.
She was right.
That was my thing about that shit.
[inaudible] I know.
That's the way parenting used to be.
The mom used to kick the shit out of you and the dad didn't have to kick the
shit out of you.
All he had to do is go and you fucking peed yourself a little bit.
And that was it.
So that's when I got out of that clip,
man,
that's just bad parenting.
That kid should have never gotten it.
That was my kid.
That kid would have been stuffed upside down in a fucking hamper and slid down a
flight of fucking stairs.
Huh?
How about that?
How about your point now?
How does that feel?
All right.
Give him a little ass.
Kickings where you,
you only end up with one shoe on.
You know,
I used to do a bit about that on stage.
I don't know if I ever fucking,
uh,
I might have to bring that one back.
Speaking of that first question that I had,
I used to do a bit of,
but anytime you get beat up by five or more people,
you always lose a shoe,
you know,
to help.
It was that like,
you know,
you get your ass kicking your ass kicked when there's like debris of you
afterwards and you have to like collect your personal belongings.
Oh fuck.
I remember what the,
how did the hell did it go?
Somehow the tag was something about having a deck of cards.
I had a deck of KBC,
the jacket diamonds,
like just your shit was just that him,
I can't remember how the fuck it went.
But anyways,
um,
so if you want to see what old school parenting looks like it,
but in a funnier way,
there is another youtube clip.
Watch this.
This clip.
It's called spoiled kid gets yelled at and uh,
yeah,
the guy yelling in.
This is basically my dad.
All right.
This is the funny version of it,
of what he really had to do and was totally in the right.
Um,
when he did it,
like I don't have any,
uh,
that's my thing.
You know what?
The old school parenting,
you know,
it bothered me as a kid,
but when I look back on it now,
it's like I deserved so many ass.
Kickings so many fucking ass kick.
I deserved him.
I fucking deserve to
ever.
One time one of my brother's Piss me off and I took out a garden hose and I
started spraying it through the fucking,
uh,
I was so mad cause I had a water,
the plants and he was making fun of me and I just took this thing and I fucking,
I just,
I,
you know,
I had a temper,
I just sprayed it right at him,
right into the house.
And uh,
you know,
and that was the day I learned what dark tastes like.
My mother,
we had me was on my back just pushing my face into the mud.
Oh yeah that was,
those were the days.
And then all your other siblings would stand around laughing cause your mother
couldn't hear the laughter over the rage.
She always focus on the one part is we're just laughing and then you come in
with your mud covered face crying and everybody just laughs.
Just Ah,
Shit.
I used to see you.
I remember back in the day,
I remember seeing one of my,
one of my friends mouthed off to his mother,
I went over to his house to get some lunch and he mouthed off to his mom
and he wanted to see when a dessert or something and she was just like,
no,
it's lunchtime.
You don't get any dessert.
And he can just go.
So mom,
I hate you.
Like we were little kids and the kids' Dad did not even look up from his
sandwich.
Just took a whole glee kids,
whole glass of milk and just threw it face.
So my friend just starts crying,
right?
The dad goes back to eat sandwich and then the mother just got up right on cue,
went over and just cleaned it up.
And that was it.
And I can guarantee you that kid never said,
oh mom,
I hate you again.
This whole fucking time out shit.
I know that's a hacky bit,
but I really believe it.
I really believe that.
You know,
you got to slap him around.
You gotta you gotta you know gotta hit,
you know I had a really hard,
I'm not talking about literally abusing them,
but yeah,
you've got to throw a glass of milk in their face.
You got to grow,
you got gotta basically ruined one of their shirts.
And by that I mean grab them by the front of it and lift them up by it to the
point where all their body weight is on the neck of the shirt and it rips a
little bit and leaves that red mark that goes past your fucking collar bone down
to your sternum.
There's a whole generation of kids,
listen to this day,
have no idea what I'm talking about.
But anybody remotely my age is punching the dashboard right now.
Laughing,
remembering all of this shit.
I don't know.
Did it make us better people?
I don't fucking know,
but we shut the fuck up at dinner.
All right,
let's continue.
Um,
question,
uh,
Bill,
would you ever consider a hosting a late night talk show?
I would.
I think I would love to do that.
Um,
I would love to do that.
Provided I could do my monologue,
like my standup and I could really just sort of a do what I do in a cleaner,
cleaner way.
I guess.
I would love to do that.
And,
uh,
I think I could actually ask some really interesting questions.
Um,
you know,
and I'm not going to give away what the fucking questions.
So I'm talking a little shit.
Go a little rex Ryan on you here.
Go to the Little Rex Ryan on you here.
Um,
yeah,
I would love,
I would love doing that,
but,
um,
I,
my career has not gone down that direction.
So that's like a whole thing where I think you have to decide you want to be a
broadcaster.
Um,
like Jon Stewart,
like early on,
like I remember hearing like he just was this phenomenal comedian and then he
just really early on started going down that road of being a broadcaster and you
get seen as that.
So,
uh,
I don't know.
Who knows?
Never say never.
If they gave me the opportunity now with fucking take it in a second,
I would take it in a fucking second.
Um,
all right,
here's some advice.
All right.
Uh,
but,
but uh,
all right.
Pill.
Let me paint you this picture for a moment.
I used to be terrible with girls.
I was always a nice guy,
but that gets you nowhere.
Oh,
Jesus.
Exactly.
Girls always said I was really nice,
but uh,
they were never interested.
This was because I lacked confidence and wasn't sure of myself.
There you go.
Get this guy taking responsibility for himself.
It's exactly yet so as time went on,
I got a few practice girls in my conference inevitably grow and I started doing
well.
There you go right there.
All you youngsters,
young guys out there.
Nice guys trying to get fucking laid.
There it is.
That's page one right there.
You're a nice guy.
You're fucking boring them.
All right.
You gotta be a little bit of a Dick,
right?
Nia is,
you walk in and try to have respect for the podcast.
How much look at you.
I can see it on your face right now.
These,
she's doing that classic girl thing where she's trying not to smile and she's
rolling her fucking eyes and you know it.
You gotta be a little bit of a cocky ass hole.
You got to come up.
You got an insult them a little bit.
Yeah,
you do.
Like if I saw you right now,
even though I like your outfit,
I would walk up to you and be like,
what did you come straight from?
Work.
That's how you dress when you come out.
And you'd be like,
what?
I'm just fucking with you.
What are you drinking right Outta the gate.
Come right out.
Put your balls right on the fucking table.
Take a look at him,
sweetie.
I'm just trying to grow she out now.
Whenever you got to Charmin,
do what she gotta do.
I don't like your fucking sandals.
I don't like him.
I've been meaning to tell you.
Oh,
that was a good one.
Right in the fucking leg.
Beat it.
See that?
She just gave me the finger and she walked out.
See right there.
That's the little ebb and flow you have to have in your relationship.
See if you're always complimenting them.
You know what?
Women are like the leg dogs,
right?
This is a record for me.
I've gone 46 minutes without trashing women.
Um,
yeah,
they like dogs.
They really are.
As much as they try to say we like dogs,
people,
I've just like fucking dog.
She can't reward them all the God damn time stroke in the back of that Goddamn
head.
Next thing you know,
there's shitting on the rug.
Okay?
If he wants to know why,
I got to give him a little discipline.
Tell him you don't like what they're wearing.
Um,
anyways,
so he was a guy.
He fee figured it out.
Why am I not getting laid?
I don't have confidence.
So what do I need to do?
I need to go out there and get some at bats.
That's what you do.
You go out there and you start talking some shit and you're going to bomb and
you're going to embarrass yourself,
but eventually you're going to push through and all those times you embarrass
yourself.
They're just,
they're just going to become,
they're just going to,
they're just going to be funny stories to tell.
Um,
no,
she's,
do I have a funny one?
I remember when I used to try to go to dance clubs,
which were totally weren't my saint,
cause not only was I not good looking enough to be in there,
I didn't know how to dance and couldn't dance and I would just walk up to girls
and my opening line was I would yell,
Hey,
do you want to dance?
And then they would go,
no.
And then I walk away.
Yeah.
Oh.
And it would take me at least another 40 minutes if I did to get the courage to
approach another one.
And that's the thing you broads.
Don't fucking appreciate.
You know,
what are you going to do?
Well you got to sit there and pluck Yahoo has and pick the right fucking colored
dog,
make sure it matches your bra.
You get to do all of that.
And private.
We got to sit there and basically it's like doing standup.
The only way to learn how to do is you have to go on stage and just eat your
balls.
You've got to bomb.
Um,
I dunno,
I guess it all gets made up because they get pregnant and they got to deal with
that fucking Shit,
you know?
And if forget about the pain of pregnancy,
can you imagine another thing growing inside of you?
Jesus.
I would go to the doctor and be like,
get this out of me.
This,
this virus.
It can,
it's,
it's eating my guts.
No,
no,
no.
That's what's supposed to happen.
Get it out.
Um,
all right.
Anyways,
let's continue here.
So a time went on and I realize how ignorant all that.
That was.
All right ladies,
ladies,
it's ladies night today.
It's ladies day morning on the Monday morning podcast.
I should have a lady's morning.
Shouldn't I?
A ladies night on the Monday morning podcast,
you know,
then I'll play clips.
I should do that and just be honoring you while I fucking just trash you in my
own roundabout Canty way.
That's what I'll do.
I'll just play,
okay.
Okay.
All right.
I'm back.
I just ran out of battery power.
God Damn.
And I was on a nice roll there.
That always makes the editing difficult.
I apologize.
Everybody the fuck happened.
Um,
you know what's funny too is I went and I bought a whole bunch of these two
double a batteries.
You know,
my girl was like,
we need more Jabil aid batteries.
He by AA battery.
So I'm always using them.
Right.
So I go down to the God damn cvs and I buy like this big fucking yeah,
12 pack of them.
12 AA batteries.
I go up to the package just like one left fucking Goddamn fucking women.
No matter what you buy,
it's not enough.
It's never a fun.
I just go take a battery out of some God damn thing that she owns.
No,
not a vibrator.
Yes.
Fucking filthy ass holes.
It's actually this baby monitor so we can watch the dog in here.
Which crate training the motherfucker.
Um,
so we sit here and watch this.
Why we couldn't,
we just use our laptops and skyped it,
you know,
sent the signal up to the fucking satellite,
whatever.
Let's get back on track here.
I swear to God if I bought the 24 pack,
they would still only be one left.
Okay,
well I just replaced the batteries and everything just in case.
Why is it illegal to slap you?
Okay,
let's plot.
That's so me.
I would never do that.
Okay ladies,
let's relax.
All right,
so let's,
let's plow ahead here.
Let me,
let me get through the advice here so I can watch the Monday night football,
what you guys are probably already doing.
Um,
so anyways,
so this guy here,
so as time went on,
it got my confidence.
I started doing well,
I reserve the right,
uh,
oh.
Anyways,
you know,
I didn't become cocky.
Start acting like I'm God's gift to women because I know,
um,
I,
you know,
I'm not that mentality and it's for dickheads.
Uh,
so anyways,
this guy has been through a considerable amount of women.
I'm trying to paraphrase here cause this is a really long email.
He ends up meet meeting this girl,
everything's going great.
Um,
he's having a good time with her.
After some time,
this guys from Ireland,
he says after some time,
uh,
the blow jobs in sex altogether had started to diminish.
I had a pair of phrase because he wrote a ton of information there.
Basically,
he meets this girl,
everything's going great that basically drinking and fucking,
and everything's often,
and then,
you know,
it starts tapering off.
So,
uh,
so it starts tapering off and she started to use sex as a weapon.
Uh,
she play mental games with me and it,
and I'd end up feeling like a bastard when she'd shoot me down for sex.
I'd say,
that's cool.
I don't mind that I excuse myself.
Go to the bathroom and crank one out.
There you go sir.
That's what you do.
You know when,
when you get to that fucking Kevin Spacey,
Beautiful Mind Level,
your rub one out right in front of her.
Never.
I've never done that,
but I think that,
that's awesome.
Um,
anyways,
he goes,
um,
so anyways,
I still got to empty the barrel,
but she wasn't involved.
And when I tried to talk to her calmly about what she was,
see what she was thinking and how she was feeling,
it would never go well.
She returned on the waterworks and play the victim,
even though she was the one who instigated the mind fucking,
I'm not sure what her reject objective was because the concept of emotional
blackmail is a foreign concept to me.
Um,
I had always tried to approach everything with a rational under understanding
basis so that she wouldn't feel targeted or threatened.
Um,
I should also add that it took a lot for me to sit down calmly and talk while
accepting criticism from her as I'm a very direct and often angry fella.
Well,
that's the only red flag there.
Other than that,
you seem like you'd take your shit and you give it as well.
Now you got to watch the younger dude.
Trust me.
I can speak volumes of that.
Uh,
I'm not the best guy in the world,
so you can imagine how difficult it was not to punch her in her cunt face.
Okay.
This is getting a little uglier.
Uh,
as soon as she started crying,
as I see crying as a school yard scape goat for girls to get what they want
because they know men don't know how to handle it.
All right,
I'm with you with everything right up to there.
Sometimes women do cry because they're upset.
They do have access to that emotion more than we do.
And I know,
but I know that angry feeling you have where you're like,
this is how you have to gauge that is basically if they cry every time then you
can call bullshit.
But if they only cry once in a fucking Blue Moon,
then you have to realize that you've really upset them and yeah,
and then you just got to deal with that.
That fucking awkwardness of not knowing what to do and then also feeling like a
bully but there's nothing worse.
I will agree with you that if your right and you haven't done anything wrong and
then they start crying and then you know,
you can't be a dick in that moment,
but you don't,
that doesn't mean you have just cause they're crying doesn't mean you have to
apologize if you're fucking right.
You don't have to apologize.
Uh,
but there is that thing where if you make a female cry,
I mean,
if you're any sort of a guy,
it's very difficult to just stand there and be like,
what?
I don't give a fuck.
You cried,
cried,
cried some more.
Huh?
Like you're the dead guy and a the great Santini he's going to shed a few start
bouncing a basketball off the back of their head.
You can't be that guy.
All right,
so let's plow ahead here.
Um,
and anyways,
females,
if you want to chime in there a lady's,
um,
what's the deal with the crew?
Like what percentage of it is bullshit?
Can I get an honest fucking woman out there?
I mean,
God knows guys,
we have our techniques to get out of Shit,
man.
They're fucking pathetic.
And you see right through them and I know right now you like,
why are you just rubbing their fucking muffs right now?
Because that's a strategy to win arguments.
You just keep feeding their fucking ego.
There's a lot of women out there who really believe that guys are so fucking
dumb that they can't get anything past him and that's a great place for them to
continue existing as far as I'm concerned.
Um,
oh yeah.
Yeah.
No one can get anything by you.
You're just fucking,
yeah,
you're the fucking goddamn world police with,
you know,
you have vagina.
You fucking know everything.
Yeah.
I can't get anything by you.
You are all powerful.
I bow down in front of the,
um,
you know,
and it was funny about that.
Yet any magazine out there can just,
you know,
fashion magazine can just tap into their fucking insecurities and get them to
buy the dumbest,
stupidest fucking war paint to put on their fucking face because some amazing
created,
I don't know,
nee knocked pitch and towed fucking drugged up Twat is wearing it,
but you can't get it out.
You can't get anything past them yet.
That's great.
My voice just cracked right there.
Can't get a lake past.
Um,
um,
I'm sorry.
I'm actually getting over a cold if you haven't,
if you can't tell,
how did you get the cold bill?
Was it from traveling the country and doing all that press notice and it's cause
they played a game of football and the fucking rain in street clothes before
Monday night football last week.
I'm sorry,
I was amped up.
Um,
anyways,
let's plow ahead.
So,
uh,
basically this guy deals with her for the next two fucking months and he finally
ends up just saying he woke up one day and said,
gets you a shape out of my flat.
This,
this is over.
I can't deal with these mind games.
So what do I get to his question here?
Um,
anyways,
I don't have much of an ego.
I like to accept my faults.
You know what,
dude?
You've said that one too many times where I'm starting to think maybe you do and
maybe this woman is buried in a new fucking turnip garden in your backyard.
I like to accept my faults and admit what I have done is wrong and learn from it
so as not to make the same mistakes over and over again.
My question is,
Bill,
how do I get them to fuck up and stop testing my patients and how do I meet
someone who doesn't want to control me with their bullshit games?
Um,
I dunno dude.
I,
half of this,
I'm really going with you when you seem like an introspective person and the
other half you've worded this kind of like a psycho.
How do you get them to fuck up and stop testing your pain?
Like testing your patients?
That's kind of like a,
I pictured Dick Cheney type guy saying something like that.
What the fuck do I know?
Basically,
I don't know what your problem is in this email.
Okay.
You dated a girl,
she started playing mind games with you and all it was was after two months you
were like,
fuck this,
pack up your shit and get out of my life.
Um,
so be one thing.
If he was still in the relationship,
then I would say that you have problems.
But you don't,
you,
uh,
you met a psycho.
So what I would say is,
uh,
I dunno,
just stay single,
stay single right now and wait until you find someone who doesn't,
uh,
try to mind.
Fuck you.
The problem is you sound like a younger guy and the problem is,
is what you're learning is that the crazy girls,
they,
they're really down for anything when it comes to sex and uh,
that's really hard to resist in your 20s.
So,
uh,
what I would say is in the future is when you meet a girl like that is not to
get involved in a fucking relationship,
but,
uh,
you know,
Bang them and you know,
get your stories out because it'll prevent you from having a midlife crisis
later on in life.
Am I helping you out?
I don't know.
I mean,
I'm kind of giving you shit here,
but I'm also a,
I'm trying,
you know,
what I'm really doing right here is you're basically bearing the brunt of the
fact that I've trashed women so much in the last 10 minutes.
I have to try to seem like I'm balanced here and then I don't understand exactly
what the fuck you're saying.
Um,
but I think,
I think you're fine.
She tried to play that mind game with you.
You didn't lose your shit.
You said,
according to you anyways,
you said I'm fine.
You went in your rub one out,
you banged her for two fucking months and one day you're like,
what am I doing?
And you just said,
yeah,
pack up.
He shouldn't get outta here.
So,
uh,
I would not,
this woman is not a good example of a,
of a good woman.
All right?
So don't try to act like all women are like this.
Like I have for a long time and like I do every week on my podcast just for
comedic purposes.
I like trash in them.
It's fun and it's childish,
but they're not all like that.
If you're young,
there's still great girls out there.
Go out and go find them.
And,
uh,
I dunno.
Make a list of what you're looking for.
And then you also have to realize,
dude,
that you know,
everybody's going to come with their faults like you with your temper.
Um,
you know,
you got your faults,
so there you go.
Did I help you out?
I probably didn't.
It probably didn't help that.
I fucking paraphrased your fucking email.
And then I also,
uh,
lost the batteries here in my,
um,
my God damn recorder.
Uh,
am I going to end with that with a whimper?
You guys want to do a quick revenge story?
Sure.
We all do a,
hey bill.
I'm not much for shit jokes,
but I thought you might be interested in one of my revenge stories when I was in
high school,
there was this kid who was always giving me and my friend Shit.
So we decided,
uh,
no wait,
I just read that wrong.
When I was in high school,
there was a kid who was always giving my friend and I shit.
So we decided we'd give him some look at that.
What a well worded shit joke.
It's got a little foreshadowing going on there.
Perfect amount of words.
If the reader was a little bit better,
that would have got a left.
So anyways,
he goes,
uh,
he was the guy who would knock people's lunch trays out of their hands in high
school and high five his buddies and laugh.
So he's basically like that kid who was in the Cobra Kai in the karate kid,
whatever that actor's name is,
who played that dude all the time.
He was in back to school.
He was the Goto Dick and all those movies.
Anyways,
he was the guy who would knock a live [inaudible].
My friend and I were known as the punk or skater kids.
What's I always thought was funny since we were just normal kids who happen to
play music and would occasionally skateboard for transportation.
Yeah.
Punk skater kids.
You think that that kid was just a football player?
I'm sure he,
maybe he liked cooking also.
You didn't watch the breakfast club.
We stereotype at that age.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
which,
kids that are the,
sorry,
I keep losing my place here on anyways,
this asshole who will call Kent would try and start fight what fights with us in
halls and would have his minions come up and push us from behind and runaway.
Nice to see.
Nothing has changed in high school.
Um,
we honestly didn't give a shit about those kids,
so we ignored,
ignored them most of the time.
Um,
subutex,
they were bigger than us and we didn't feel like getting our asses kicked.
Um,
but finally the day came,
Ken came up,
this is where they can't take it no more.
I like this.
Finally,
the day came up,
Ken came up to my friend in the parking lot,
grabbed his skateboard out of his hand,
throw it on the ground and stuck his chin out saying,
hit me.
Come on,
you fucking faggot.
Hit me.
Was this kid,
was he reading from a bed coming of age script?
Mind you,
my friend has never said a fucking word to this prick.
So I go,
yeah,
go ahead.
Fuck an Adam.
Kent then says to me,
uh,
you don't even want to fucking try.
I'll fucking kick your punk ass.
Jesus.
This is right out of the bully handbook.
Uh,
but me being a,
but my friend being a smart ass said my punk ass or my sky ass in purse
proceeded to sky dance around Kent.
It was one of the funniest things I've ever seen.
I don't know what sky dancing is.
Is that the move in that moment and is,
if,
are you two going to reinvent the personal computer?
Is this one?
This is what I see in your future.
Anyways,
let's continue on with this.
Here.
I,
that night we went to Taco bell to get some food and decided to take revenge.
We each took our to go bags into the bathroom and looked,
it took one of the most satisfying shits of our lives.
So you guys sitting in different stalls snickering at the son of your own shit,
hitting a plastic bag.
There's a lot of layers to this.
Uh,
this movie here.
It's got the classic bully.
It's got the two nerds.
They're bonding,
sort of got a scat theme to it with a little Scott dancing.
You know,
if you,
if you write a treatment,
you could probably get it made in this weird economy out here and now in
Hollywood.
All right,
let's plow to plow ahead here where we put the bags of shit in the trunk of my
car.
Please tell me you double bagged and drove over to,
and at this point,
this kid,
so into the story,
he actually writes this kid's real name,
but we'll still call him Kent.
Uh,
we emptied a,
emptied the bags of shit into his mailbox while trying not to throw up from the
smell.
The combination of our shit almost made a slurry and it was leaking out of the
sides of the mailbox.
Jesus Christ.
We spent out of the neighborhood but didn't get too far because we were both
laughing so fucking hard.
I could barely keep the vehicle on the road.
The next week at school,
I heard some kids talking about what happened to Kent's mailbox.
I couldn't help but smile every time someone mentioned it.
And from then on Kent's new nickname at school was shitbox.
Uh,
my hope you enjoyed my disgusting story.
But uh,
I'm not usually one for revenge or shit jokes,
but this asshole deserved it.
I love the podcasts.
All right,
well there you go.
That's one way of what's he supposed to do?
We can't kick the shit out of him.
So he shits in a bag with his friend and they dump it into his mailbox.
There you go.
People were going to end on that.
We're going to end on that.
The dungeons and dragons
venge story.
Um,
I mean,
well,
what happened?
Did you ever find out why that is unsatisfying to me?
Did can't go out there and reaching for his bully magazine and got a handful of
a combined shit from the two of you or did his poor mom,
you know,
we had to carry that bully around in is in her,
in her womb for nine months.
I don't know.
I don't know what to do with it.
I got all thrown off with my fucking,
the whole thing out of the goddamn
tape recorded crapping out on me.
Anyways,
that's the podcast for this week.
Ended on a whimper rather than a roar.
Thanks to everybody who listens to the podcast and a Monday morning podcast.
Please go to the [inaudible] podcast.com please buy my new special,
um,
let it go on DVD by a couple of them.
Show your support.
God bless Ya.
And uh,
if you want the Oh Jesus,
ring tone,
if you can't afford a DVD of fucking understand that it's a crazy economy right
now.
I'm just go to the [inaudible] podcast.com and for 99 cents can get the o ring
tone and a,
if you can't afford that,
who gives a fuck?
Come back next week and you have another free podcast.
All right.
Once again,
thanks to everybody who helped me try to have a height,
my special,
uh,
I'm going to go watch the sates
sets.
You want to talk to you?
Yeah.